موقع المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي ينصح
المؤسسات بضروره التركيز على احتضان
المواهب بدلا من النظر الى الشهادات
الجامعيه فقط ورشح ثلاث خطوات ربما تساعد
على تحقيق ذلك اولا تدريب وتطوير الموظفين
الحاليين في الشركه ما يوفر الوقت والمال
المطلوبين عند التوظيف الخارجي وعند فتح
باب التوظيف يفضل البحث عن الاشخاص
القابلين للتعلم وهي اهم مهاره بالنظر
للمتغيرات المتلاحقه والمهارات الجديده
التي ستكون مطلوبه في المستقبل ثالثا
التوظيف على اساس الاداء المتوقع بدلا من
التوظيف على اساس الخبرات السابقه وهو نهج
يساعد على الوصول الى اصحاب الافكار
الابداعيه وتطوير المواهب اخيرا اجراء
محادثات مهنيه منتظمه مع الموظفين فهذا
يساعد في ترسيخ ثقافه التعلم وزي اده
انتاجيه الموظفين وشعورهم بالانتماء على
كل حال سالنا الناس في السعوديه هل انت مع
الشهاده الجامعيه ام الخبره العمليه
لتحقيق النجاح لنتابع
[موسيقى]
انا مش مع الشهاده ولا مع الخبره انا مع
اي مهاره ممكن الواحد يكسب منها رزق حلال
انا معاه الخبره العمليه ماني مع الشهاده
الجمعيه ابدا
يعني الا في حاله واحده انك تكون الجمعيه
يعني مهندس الخبره العمليه
افضل معلم الممارسه
الشهاده يعني بس الخبره عمليه افضل مع
الشهاده الجامعيه اكيد
اكيد الواحد يدرس ويتعلم ويكون الخبره مع
الشهاده الجامعيه طبعا انا مع المهارات
اكثر من خبره ومن الشهاده اوكي الخبره
حلوه لكن المهارات اهم انا والله مع
الاثنين يعني الخبره والشهاده يعني اذا
كانوا مع بعض اتوقع يعني
حيكون يعني حاجه كويسه يعني طبعا الخبره
العمليه يعني طبعا انا مع خبرتي هي الخبره
العمليه هي اللي ساعدتني اني اتاهل
لوظيفتي لا بصراحه الخبره الخبره هي اللي
تثبت النجاح
وهذا عن تجربه طبعا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات